fight
dude
hmm
[Music]
yes
everyone keeps secrets
sometimes it's the only way to protect
the ones we love
[Music]
i know you
god killer
[Music]
what is it you want from
me is it a god of war you came to find
[Music]
you don't really want war
do you kratos
all that blood on your hands on your
son's hands
what is it you will not tell me
i can't talk about it but i just need
you to trust me
we follow your every whim but you don't
believe in any of it and still i follow
because all that matters is that you are
safe but that's not all that matters
who's keeping you safe
i do not need you to protect me
sure about that
pretender god
for the old father death can happen
when it burns me
what do you even know
of godhood
in your lifetimes has anyone ever
worshipped you
ever prayed to you
can you even imagine that kind of love
no
you don't care about anything beyond
yourself
beyond the monster who kills without
cause
[Music]
fate only binds you if you let
[Music]
do it necessary
not because it is written
[Music]
we will make our own destiny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
after three centuries of the tokugawa's
repressive rule
the black ships appeared without warning
and our nation began to tear itself
apart
those who cleave to the past
those who embrace the new
and the ronin
a warrior free of all masters and bonds
[Music]
i will watch over you all
as your blades carve a new future
your time has come
rise
as one
huh
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign